Speaker 1: Last week.
Our great guest host who filled in for me,
did a great job covering the plea agreement
that Hunter Biden has reached with the Justice
Department.
I don't really have much to add other than
my position has always been.
If there's evidence that Hunter Biden did
anything wrong, investigate him.
If it points to charges, charge him and then
either try him or strike a plea deal, do don't
do anything special for the guy because he
is the son of President Joe Biden.
Okay.
So that happened.
And now the right is starting to cook up all
sorts of additional conspiracy theories.
Of course, many on the right are saying, well,
he was able he was allowed to get a plea deal
that avoids prison time because he's the son
of Joe Biden.
There's no evidence of that.
The evidence is that his his plea deal was
very much in line with what many would see
if they are represented by competent counsel
in such a situation.
So that line isn't going very well for the
right.
So the new one is this is just so, so amazing.
Over the weekend as attention went to this
failed coup attempt in Russia, which we talked
about at the top of the show over on Fox News,
Maria BARTIROMO yesterday came up with the
conspiracy theory that the entire coup attempt
might have been fabricated to take attention
away from Hunter Biden, if you can believe
that.
And you might say, David, that doesn't make
any sense.
There's no evidence for that, of course.
Of course.
But we're operating or they are operating
in a different world.
Listen to this.
Oh.
We have a glitched clip.
I'm glitching almost as badly as Trump.
Hold on.
Here we go.
So does it break through and.
Speaker 2: Become a real problem?
The White House wanted to give the media something
else to cover.
Right.
This is the M.O.
This is exactly the way they do things.
In fact.
Speaker 1: The White House wanted to give
the media something else to cover.
Okay.
Speaker 2: Friday, I said, wow, what a blockbuster
WhatsApp message.
I'm sure there will be an enormous story over
the weekend that the White House is going
to be pushing to take this story off of the
front page.
And sure enough, we've got the State Department
drumming up all the drama that took place
over the weekend in Russia.
So I don't know if it's going to break through.
The mainstream media has has an excuse again,
not to cover it.
They're covering everything about Russia and
the Wagner Group.
Yeah, it's true.
As if it really matters to the US right now.
Yeah, you may.
Speaker 1: Right.
As if it matters to the US.
Whether the authoritarian leader of one of
the three global superpowers of which the
US is one.
As if it matters whether they are deposed
in a coup.
And it doesn't really matter.
And it's distracting from the Hunter Biden
story.
What on earth is wrong with these people?
And it's important to remember that according
to them, the first Trump arrest was meant
to distract from something.
And now I actually don't remember.
I don't remember if it was inflation.
Does anybody in the audience remember what
the first Trump arrest was meant to distract
from?
Was it something about Biden Biden tripping
or something like that?
Anyway, the first Trump arrest was meant to
be a distraction from that.
The second Trump arrest was meant to be a
distraction from the explosive claims of a
whistleblower about Joe Biden, a whistleblower
they can't find whose recordings may not exist.
That was that was the second the reason for
the second Trump arrest.
And then now the entire Russian coup attempt
is to distract from Hunter Biden.
A potential coup that would destabilize an
adversarial superpower that also happens to
have gobs of nuclear weapons.
Not really a story.
What matters much more is Hunter Biden using
drugs and his WhatsApp text messages or something
like that.
Once again, the details.
Hunter Biden has pleaded guilty or will plead
guilty to two tax misdemeanors and he struck
a deal to also resolve a gun charge, according
to the Justice Department.
He failed to pay at least 100 K in taxes in
2017 and 2018 by their deadlines.
He has since fully repaid those taxes as well
as the fines, and he unlawfully possessed
a gun for 11 days in 2018.
He knew he wasn't supposed to have a gun and
that that's what happened.
So he has struck a deal.
And the good news is that now that we see
that Hunter Biden did have to face consequences,
we can all rest easy knowing that it's not
only Trump who is going to have to be adjudicated
for the things he allegedly did.
Right.
Are we ready to say that the two tiered justice
system of Republicans and Democrats isn't
actually a thing?
No, we're not.
Because the new argument is Hunter got a sweetheart
deal because he's a Democrat and the son of
Joe Biden.
This is a reminder, I told you guys this a
year ago.
If they ever do go after Hunter Biden, the
right isn't going to let up.
They will simply say he wasn't charged seriously
enough or he was given a light sentence or
a slap on the wrist or whatever because of
Joe Biden.
And that is exactly what they are now saying